two days ago republicans in wyoming
voted overwhelmingly to oust liz cheney
from congress
there was no fraud
there were no shenanigans the vote was
66.3
to 28.9 about as clear as a vote can
possibly get
they didn't change all the election laws
right beforehand to benefit the other
candidate as democrats nationwide did in
2020 they didn't pause the vote count
for days and weeks it was a clear win
for cheney's opponent a clear loss for
cheney or in the mind of the liberal
media a threat to democracy
a close watch on wyoming and what
happens there tonight could add to a
trend and that is election deniers
winning primaries around the nation what
does that mean for our democracy and the
risk of more chaos like what we saw on
january 6.
what does it mean for our democracy that
the voters voted for someone that the
libs don't like
oh that seems pretty scary for our
democracy according to hollywood
meathead rob reiner quote liz cheney's
overwhelming loss makes it abjectly
clear
the republican party has abandoned
american democracy and fealty to a
sociopathic criminal
and according to morning joe you look at
the legislative achievements you look at
how we have come together uh as a
country around ukraine you look at the
fact the united states is once again
leading the way in protecting democracy
in europe
by these metrics the united states is
functioning better than they have in
quite some time but there is i'll say it
a rump of the republican party which is
yes it's the it's the it's the dominant
force and and the pri in republican
primaries but it's about 38 39 of the
electorate
that want to replace the us government
that that want to throw away american
democracy
it's that 38 percent of the electorate
that
actually is 66 percent of the electorate
that just voted out liz cheney they're
the threat you see the the
vast majority of people
are actually
a small minority of people when they
oppose what i joe scarborough want you
see the problem with that argument
the libs are saying that when voters
reject them or reject their officially
approved fake republicans at the polls
that undermines democracy
when the voters vote for something that
the liberals don't like that undermines
democracy which of course makes no sense
until you realize that when liberals use
the word democracy
they don't really mean democracy
they mean liberalism leftism
progressivism it's not the same thing
when voters elect right-wing candidates
that undermines democracy according to
the libs when unaccountable elites
install left-wing candidates and
policies that supports democracy
according to the libs
right now democracy and the leftism of
our elites are in conflict with one
another
expect many more attacks on democracy
and do not expect them to be coming from
the right i'm michael knowles is the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from phil veda who
says giving liz cheney any credit for
voting conservative most of the time is
like going home to your wife and letting
her know that you've been faithful to
her most of the time
mostly peaceful means violent mostly
loyal means disloyal let cheney be an
example of what happens when you squish
of course that is true that is such a
great point it's like
going and giving your husband a drink
you make him a cocktail
and you make him a really nice cocktail
you say wow this is a delicious cocktail
and then you just put a few drops of
arsenic in it
you say no i didn't poison my husband i
made him a nice cocktail no well you
know it's that kind of that little bit
that counts it's that kind of the
crucial
deciding bit
that counts and that's what determines
a squish you know
we are going to have to stop relying on
these unaccountable elites that hate our
guts we're gonna have to start doing for
ourselves when you want to
fix your own car you got to check out
rock auto right now head on over to
rockauto.com and write knolls in there
how did you hear about us box rock auto
has been in the auto parts business for
20 years family owned their goal is to
make auto parts available and affordable
to keep you safe on the road the thing i
love about these guys they're so
straightforward no gimmicks no
sign in at this hour to get 20 to 40 off
no it's always reliably low prices the
lowest prices you're gonna find anywhere
same price for pros and
do-it-yourselfers the selection is so
easy to navigate even i can do it
one time i had a buddy of mine he
thought he was gonna he was gonna do
better than rock auto he went to a
brick-and-mortar auto parts store i'm
not gonna tell you which one he asks for
the part
they tried to charge him 400 he looks it
up on rock auto which takes two seconds
on his phone 150 bucks
they tried to charge him more than
double don't let that happen to you go
to rockauto.com get brakes shocks carpet
wipers headlights mirrors mufflers lug
nuts or any other part you need
rockauto.com be sure to write knolls in
their how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you
liz cheney lost
i don't know i don't know how i'm
probably going to be spiking the
football in this for several weeks she
lost the democracy spoke
the people spoke
and the democracy doesn't like
the libs
so liz cheney lost
and in losing
this woman compared herself i kid you
not
to abraham lincoln
the great and original champion of our
party abraham lincoln was defeated in
elections for the senate and the house
before he won the most important
election of all
lincoln ultimately prevailed he saved
our union
and he defined our obligation as
americans for all of history
speaking at gettysburg of the great task
remaining before us lincoln said
that we here highly resolve
that these dead shall not have died in
vain that this nation under god shall
have a new birth of freedom and that
government of the people by the people
and for the people shall not perish from
this earth
she's a regular old abraham lincoln
isn't she and it's not just that she's
making these kinds of comparisons to
bluster to try to fix her wounded pride
after getting absolutely destroyed with
facts and logic during this republican
primary in wyoming
liz cheney i kid you not
is actively considering
running for president are you thinking
about running for president
it uh that's a decision that i'm going
to make in the in the coming months
savannah i'm not going to make any
announcements here this morning but uh
but it is something that i i'm thinking
about and i'll make a decision uh in the
coming months
makes sense if you get just completely
blown out of the water as a republican
in an extremely red state running for
congress it would make perfect sense of
course that you would then run
for president when you have no support
in your own party you have kind of tepid
support among the democrats they'll use
liz cheney while she's useful to them
while she's attacking the republicans
they don't actually like her they're not
going to vote for her for anything but
they'll use her until she's no longer
useful to them so she's going to run for
president that makes a lot of sense
right
now why would liz cheney run probably
not to win i don't think she's under any
impression that she would win but she
just wants to stop donald trump from
being the president and donald trump
right now is the leading candidate for
the republicans in 2024 it's not even
close he's up by 40 points if the
primaries were held today he would win
decisively i'm not sure that anyone
would even run against him
and liz cheney said in her congressional
reelection campaign she said that the
most important thing we can do for
america right now is to stop donald
trump from ever being president again so
presumably she would be running for
president
not really to win but to be a spoiler
for trump and
to that i say bring it on liz sounds
great i would absolutely love liz cheney
to run for president in 2024 because she
would not be a spoiler for trump
she wouldn't she has no support in the
republican party
a lot of the votes that she got and what
did she get
she got 20 28.9 of the vote a lot of
those votes were from democrats by the
way who were encouraged to go out and
support liz cheney in the primary
to vote in the republican primary
so who knows how many republicans voted
for her in her own state with the name
cheney this was a dynastic sort of name
in politics
it's been a big name in republican
politics for 50 years now didn't matter
at all so what's her support nation wide
among republicans i don't know negative
10 percent
she would be a spoiler for the democrats
because the democrats have gone
completely insane
even the majority of democrats know that
they've gone completely insane the
majority of democrats don't want joe
biden to win in
or to run even in 2024.
biden is underwater on every single
policy issue occasionally on covet he
creeps above 50 but usually not they're
underwater on everything
and there are a lot of democrats who say
gosh i don't want these crazies running
the show and because the democrats have
pumped up liz cheney as this honorable
maverick rogue voice of reason i could
see a lot of moderate democrats
possibly pulling the lever for her
in 2024 so find by me liz i truly truly
hope she runs
she will not be a problem for the
republicans just look at the rest of the
pro-impeachment
anti-trump
pro-pelosi republicans in the house what
happened to them they just got
absolutely wrecked
in these primaries
the
80 80 of the pro-impeachment republican
members of the house will not be in the
house in 2023.
the only two who are still going to be
around are representatives david valadao
who's in california
and dan newhouse who's in washington
four of the pro-impeachment anti-trump
pro-pelosi republicans
chose not even to run again because they
knew they were going to get absolutely
blown out of the water that includes
anthony gonzalez fred upton john catko
and then my favorite adam kinzinger adam
kinzinger still just absolutely weeping
because he thought that he was going to
be able to grandstand have his have his
close-up this was going to be his
theatrical moment totally
uh totally backfired on him and then
another four pro impeachment anti-trump
pro pelosi gop members
peter meijer tom rice jaime herrera
butler and and liz cheney of course just
lost
they lost they don't have support
the people have spoken
the democracy
has spoken and the democrats don't like
that very much because they are a very
ironically named political party the
democrats seem extremely out of touch
they seem very elitist they don't seem
to have a connection to the people those
aren't my words those are the words of
the head of the d triple c the head of
the democrat congressional campaign
committee sean maloney said that just
the other day he said they seem like
elitists they seem out of touch they
seem like oligarchs is what they really
seem like and so while they well they
talk a really good game about our sacred
democracy everything that they do
seems to be
designed to mitigate the strength of the
democracy and to enshrine themselves in
power including all the ridiculous
extra-legal illegal measures they're
trying to take to stop trump from
appearing on a ballot again because they
don't want our democracy to put him back
into the white house
now we're gearing up for a fight here
folks we got to make sure that we got a
lot of iron in our blood our bellies are
full we're feeling good and satisfied
and healthy that's why you got to check
out good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what the biden
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried they're feeling it
food and gas prices are higher than i've
ever seen in my lifetime that is why i
am so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation-proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe i don't know how this works i
hope good ranchers can stay in business
this is such a good deal
you you subscribe right now you can
either buy a box of meat absolutely top
quality meat you just buy a one-off box
and you enjoy it or you can subscribe
and for the whole life of your
subscription it will never go up
do it right now this is the most insane
deal i've ever seen goodranchews.com
use code knowles at checkout you get 30
bucks off plus free shipping lock in
that price recession proof your meals
for life inflation proof your meals for
life you'll be automatically entered to
win 30 minutes by the way of all access
with me on september 30th if you do that
this offer ends august 31st we're
calling it a meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com
use code knowles at checkout
in the latest updates
from wiley coyote the wily coyote
democrats chasing the road runner trump
they've got him now
they the walls are closing in
jennifer rubin who is a fake
conservative at the washington post i
actually don't even think she calls
herself conservative anymore
coincidentally this actually hadn't
occurred to me until just now she now
calls herself pro-democracy so jennifer
rubin is a liberal columnist she for a
while was a fake republican
you know the same sort of fake
republican that you see on the view or
cnn or msnbc jennifer rubin appears on
all these liberal outlets and she says
i'm a republican i just happen to always
support democrats when it matters but
i'm a republican that's why we have
diversity of thought here on this panel
but they don't really so this became
completely untenable even for
jennifer rubin during the trump years
and so she stopped calling herself a
conservative
now she calls herself pro-democracy
but
jennifer rubin is doing her darndest to
create new legal requirements that would
stop trump from appearing on a ballot
that would that would prevent the people
from voting for trump if they so chose
and the argument she's bringing up now
is that trump took the fifth amendment
in a deposition in new york
so you know what happened in new york
the attorney general leticia james who
ran on a platform of getting trump
leticia james is going after trump's
businesses on all sorts of bogus
whatever they're just throwing spaghetti
at the wall to try to get the guy on
anything and so trump goes in there he
realizes that the system is rigged
against him the fbi the doj prosecutors
all over the place have been
ex actually breaking the law since 2016
to try to undermine his political career
so he says okay i'm not going to play
ball you people are fabricating evidence
you're raiding my home completely
unprecedented you're you're launching
years-long efforts to spy on me to to
plant evidence to do whatever to get me
out of office so i'm not going to play
ball i'm going to play the fifth c in
court
jennifer rubin says
taking the fifth amendment
should disqualify a politician from
taking office
the fifth amendment is a civil right
that you have it's it's the civil right
against self-incrimination
and she says
the defeated former president an alleged
mishandler of classified material has
every right to avoid self-incrimination
but that doesn't mean he's protected
from adverse judgment either from the
jury or
in this civil suit or from
voters
she then quotes lawrence tribe a liberal
constitutional scholar who says in a
special sense a president or a former
president more than any other public
official or private citizen arguably
betrays
his or her duty to the american people
by taking the fifth
betrays is okay and so they should be
disqualified because
you know the people in government
they've got to enforce the law and so if
you played the fifth against
self-incrimination
for some reason dot dot dot unclear you
shouldn't be able to be president
now she admits several paragraphs not
even probably 10 paragraphs down she
says
true the constitution spells out no
disqualifications for federal office
other than conviction through
impeachment and section 3 of the 14th
amendment which borrows a person from
office if they've engaged in
insurrection or rebellion or given aid
or comfort to the enemies thereof but
voters certainly should consider the
underlying conflict
when a candidate for office takes the
fifth especially when the issue goes to
the core of our democracy this is so
pathetic
this is so pathetic this is just like
last week
when the the
democrats tried to invoke some provision
of the us code some ridiculous provision
of the presidential records act or the
u.s code to say that if you ever
mishandle classified material then you
can't run for office first of all the
president can't mishandle classified
material because the president has the
right to declassify whatever he wants
whenever he wants to do it
but furthermore
our constitution
sets the rules for running for president
sets the qualifications
and there are not many
you've got to be a certain age you can't
have been impeached and convicted don't
forget the democrats impeached him twice
they never convicted him because they
had nothing on him
and so the guy can run
if the democrats are so supportive of
our democracy
they would let his name appear on the
ballot if the democrats are so confident
that our democracy would reject donald
trump and that donald trump hates our
democracy
they would let him appear on the ballot
because our democracy won't vote for him
right
but of course
what the democrats believe is that our
democracy would vote for donald trump
again
our democracy voted for donald trump at
least once
at least once
people some people have questions but at
least one time we know our democracy
elected the man
if the democrats really believed what
they were saying they'd let them appear
but but they don't
because to the dems democracy does not
mean democracy you don't just see it
with trump you don't even just see it in
america
in hungary the conservative leader in
hungary victor orban who's doing an
excellent job in that country when he
gets elected
when he gets elected by a huge margin
the western media the american liberal
press says that is a threat to democracy
when a right-wing leader in poland gets
elected that's a threat to democracy
when a right-wing leader in brazil juror
bolsonaro gets elected that's a threat
to democracy
that can only make sense
if democracy means liberalism and
progressivism they're not the same
idea they're not the same concept
and very often they're in conflict and
when they're in conflict the libs always
choose liberalism progressivism
leftism
speaking of people who want to be
president
mike pence
a loyal vice president to
donald trump seems to be
hitting the campaign trail to set the
stage for a 2024 presidential bid
and he is dis distinguishing himself
from donald trump he is saying
conservatives need to cut it out with
the attacks on the fbi
earlier today and elsewhere i
i also want to remind my fellow
republicans
we can hold the attorney general
accountable for the decision that he
made
without attacking the rank and file law
enforcement personnel at the fbi
the republican party is the party of law
and order
our party stands with the men and women
who serve on the thin blue line at the
federal and state and local level
and these attacks on the fbi must stop
calls to defund the fbi are just as
wrong as calls to defund the police
the truth the matter is
we need to get to the bottom of what
happened we need to let the facts
play out
i like mike pence he's a nice guy i
think he was a good governor of indiana
he's just completely wrong here this is
just totally wrong totally
misunderstanding
the facts
and misunderstanding the political
moment
the responsible thing to do
after the
outright lawlessness that we have seen
from the fbi
over the last five six seven years
the responsible thing to do is call for
dismantling it
if not ripping it up root and branch at
the very least fundamentally
restructuring it the fbi
at the at the behest of the doj
for
seven years now
made up evidence for a fisa court spied
on trump's campaign call let's not
forget let's fast forward a little bit
called parents domestic terrorists
if they don't want their kids to get
trans at school and don't want their
kids to learn that white people are evil
because of their race they're domestic
terrorists we were told
fbi at the behest of the doj raids the
home of a former president and the chief
political rival to the current president
the fbi and the doj work in collusion
with democrats a democrat-funded dossier
to set up donald trump to stop him from
being from president to undermine our
democracy and you say we can't raise any
questions and then what he does there is
he actually uses the same line that the
democrats use they say if you attack the
political leadership of the fbi and the
doj you're attacking the rank and file
officers i don't think that's true i
don't hear anybody attacking the rank
and file fbi officers who are going out
there and arresting
drug smugglers and child pornographers
and sex traffickers no i hear people
going after the political leadership of
those two institutions
rightly so
that's
in a similar way
you saw this during the bush
administration
any criticism of the political
leadership
any criticism of the way that that war
was being conducted was turned into an
attack on the troops
so rhetorically i guess it can be useful
but it's not a good argument at all
especially oh my gosh we're talking
about the fbi right now
the fbi actually going in and raiding
the homes of democrats political
opponents
completely misunderstanding the
situation completely misunderstanding
the moment i think it's probably an
honest mistake from mike pence he seems
like a good honorable guy i don't really
know him but he seems like a good
honorable guy
and he seems like he wants to be
president so i don't i don't know why he
would uh why he would be running on a
platform that's just so politically tone
deaf
and wrong on the facts but
not not a good look if if the man wants
to be president that that is not the way
to do it
all right things are getting hot out
there
and when you want to feel nice and cool
and look really cool and have a really
high quality clothing during the summer
you got to check out missing in maine
right now go to mizzenmaine.com use
promo code knowles you've got to check
out mizzen and maine especially in the
summer time but really all times of the
year because they combine the absolute
best of a performance fabric so you're
not if you're like me sicilian you
perspire a little bit okay the best of
that performance with a beautiful really
sharp looking dress shirt miss it in
maine combines the comfort and
flexibility of your favorite athletic
wear with the fit and style of a custom
dress shirt lightweight breathable
moisture wicking these guys will have
you looking great and the dress shirts
are machine washable so you can skip
those trips to the dry cleaner think of
all the time and money you will save by
the way their dress shirts are amazing
that's what they got famous for i think
my favorite is their polos their
performance polos are they're they feel
so great they're so slick looking
they've got no tuck shirts they got
flannel they got chinos they have
everything these guys and most important
of all as far as i'm concerned amazing
style great tailoring great style
thirty thousand five star reviews and by
the way they just turned ten so they've
got great deals running on their site
all summer long right now if you go to
mizzonmain.com use promo code knowles
you will receive 35 bucks off any
regular price order over 125 bucks that
is 35 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n-dot-com
use promo code knowles
mike pence in his comments on how we
shouldn't restructure the fbi
what he is demonstrating is something
that
some republicans and conservatives still
don't understand
the political landscape especially on
the right has shifted dramatically
yes it is true ten years ago the idea
that the republicans would criticize the
fbi would be unthinkable that's the sort
of thing the democrats do right in the
meantime the fbi has targeted
republicans and has broken the law in
some cases to attack republicans things
have changed
the political landscape has shifted
15 years ago the idea that republicans
would be the party saying hey maybe we
need to pull back on the overseas
adventurism and focus a little bit more
on the home front before we go out and
try to occupy all these different
countries around the world that would be
unthinkable republicans were the party
of foreign adventurism democrats were
the party of isolationism now that's
completely switched the
political circumstances have changed
dramatically and there's one issue where
they've shifted in particular
that people aren't talking about as much
seed oils
i'm serious seed oils
have if you if you're very online and if
you follow all the kind of online
conversations you will notice that a lot
of people and disproportionately people
on the right will talk about how there
are all sorts of things in our diet that
are really not good for us that have
been foisted on us in the last 20 30
years
and that have made us less healthy and
one of these theses is on seed oils and
i have to tell you
i am 100 seed oil pilled i was skeptical
at first
my wife kind of got me looking into this
a little bit so sweet little elisa some
other people too i looked into it and i
thought you know
i think there might be something to this
why is it that so many people on the
right
which used to defend i don't know
mcdonald's and
all gmos and seed oils and whatever we
were the ones who said oh you crazy
liberal hippies you're the ones who are
all worried about that organic whatever
crap now it seems like it's flipped
now it seems like it's the democrats who
are the supporters of the big
big corporate
chemical pumped food industry big pharma
democrats are obviously the the
defenders of big pharma that's another
issue remember 20 years ago who were the
crazy wild anti-vaxxed people they were
all on the left
and it was the right that made fun of
them and it was the right said all
vaccines are fine there are no questions
about vaccines now it's totally flipped
it's the right that's skeptical of
vaccines so why is this happen is it
just hypocrisy is it just idiocy no i
think it's
people reacting to changing
circumstances
without dr fauci
without the lies and corruption and
incompetence of the medical
establishment that we saw during kovid
i'm sure that conservatives would not
have changed their opinions on
chemicals and food or vaccines or
anything like that
but when you're in a situation now where
peop we're told if you take these
vaccines they're 100 safe there are no
side effects whatsoever and you're not
going to catch covet and you're not
going to spread covet and then it turns
out none of that is true and there are
side effects and one of the vaccines
actually gets pulled mostly from the
market because people are dying from
blood clots and there are all sorts of
questions about
about
heart enlargement and all sorts of
issues with the vaccines and then also
the vaccines don't stop you from getting
coveted and they don't stop you from
spreading cope and it's just all a big
lie
at the very least it was all totally
wrong conservatives are going to look at
that and say what else are they lying to
us about what else did they get wrong
for goodness sakes they got the food
pyramid wrong remember when we were in
school there was the food pyramid and
they said eat lots of carbs and don't
eat lots of meat or cheese or fats or
anything and then a few years ago they
said oops whoops never mind we got it
totally backwards
uh just flip it you say what what are
you talking about
well how could you get it perfectly
wrong
but they have
and so i'm not going to go into the seat
maybe i'll go deeper on the seed oil
thing a little bit later on all of that
to say
things are shifting
okay politics is not stuck in time this
is one of the big mistakes of
conservatives in 2016 who couldn't
understand trump this was the mistake of
the never trumpers
they accused the conservatives who
supported trump of being sellouts
rudderless unprincipled all the nonsense
you heard from liz cheney
when in fact the conservatives who saw
something in trump in 2016 were the ones
who were applying eternal principles
principles of justice principles of
freedom principles of all the rest that
we american conservatives cherish
they were applying that of a christian
moral order principles of all these
sorts of things they were applying that
to changing circumstances because the
conservatives who saw something in trump
in 2016 realized it's not 1983 anymore
if it were 1983 we might want a
different candidate but it's not we're
living in the world of
transiting the kids of a radical
redefinition of marriage of three
million illegal aliens coming in every
day i remember during that campaign
especially because immigration was such
a big issue you had the squishes and the
libs
would come out and say you know it's
unbelievable to think
in the 1980 presidential primaries for
the republicans
reagan and george w bush they were
trying to outdo one another on how
lenient they would be on illegal
immigration
they were the the political momentum
there was in favor of giving people
amnesty or letting more illegal aliens
in you say right
back in 1980 very few illegal aliens
were entering the country
the circumstance was totally different
back in 1980
we were promised all sorts of things by
the democrats that the democrats would
close up the border if we gave some kind
of an amnesty we heard all these things
in 2016 and in 2020 and now in 2022 we
just know that isn't true
today we have two million illegal aliens
a year crossing the board it's gonna be
more than that this year
so you apply eternal principles of mercy
and compassion and justice and the rule
of law and our democracy which passed
certain immigration laws our democracy
which if it doesn't have a say on who's
a citizen and who comes into the country
then there is no such thing as our
democracy well the situation was very
different
the the people who didn't get it
the people who were
rudderless or at the very least
misguided
it was the people who were just stuck in
the past who were just stuck ossified in
1983 when things in fact are changing
that's why we have a democracy that's
why we're not just governed by a sheet
of paper
yes we have a constitution to set up the
structures of our government to
delineate certain basic limits of
government
but we have our democracy because
politics is about applying those true
eternal wonderful things
to ever changing circumstances and if
you don't change
you will die or at the very least if you
don't accept those changing
circumstances you will die
speaking of
doctors and the medical establishment
being just completely wrong
dr jill biden
the person that whoopi goldberg wants to
be the surgeon general of the united
states dr joe biden has kovit again
dr jill biden has had four covid shots
she had the two original ones then she
got two boosters
she has coveted
she has covid after her husband had
kovid
and after he repeatedly tested positive
i wish jill biden the best recovery i
hope she gets well soon
the only reason that story matters is
that every single time
one of these libs gets covered
it takes away a little bit more of the
credibility of the medical establishment
and what do they do they make it worse
because every time the libs get it what
do they say i got kovid i'm so glad that
i got my vaccines and boosters
the thing i i
tried to do to stop getting covet didn't
work i'm so glad i did it
and you look at that and you say wow
these people are wrong about everything
they keep getting everything wrong
they're wrong in the economy they're
wrong on foreign policy they're wrong on
what you're shooting to your body so you
don't get the cough i'm going to vote
for the other guy people increasingly
are doing that
and as the democracy does that that's
allegedly a threat to our democracy now
speaking of one of those right-wing
foreign leaders that i said is called a
threat to democracy because the people
really like him that's jair bolsonaro in
brazil
bolsonaro is running for president again
and he
just
launched his
presidential campaign
in the city where a crazy lib stabbed
him
so bolsonaro was was attacked you know
we've had attacks on our conservative
politicians here in america
uh brazil they really got close and they
stabbed the guy
so what does bolsonaro do when he's
running for reelection does he go and
avoid that place
does he say okay well i'm going to stay
far away from where those crazy libs
stabbed me no
he launches the campaign
in that place the place where he says he
was born again this socialist almost
stabbed him to death in 2018
he's launching his campaign there again
this is what we've got to learn from
when the libs come at us
or right now when they come at trump but
they're really coming at trump because
trump is just a symbol of all the rest
of us it's not just about trump as a
threat to democracy increasingly the
libs are saying no it's all of trump
supporters it's half the country it's a
threat to our democracy
when they when they come at you
you've got to stand your ground you've
got to double down
you know that the libs are not as strong
as they present themselves to be they're
like the sand people in star wars you
know they they try to really they're
like a puffer fish they try to make
themselves seem a lot bigger and scarier
than they actually are you know that
they don't have a lot because trump
trump is still standing
we'll get him on ukraine we'll get him
on stormy daniels we'll get him on
russia we'll get him on this we'll get
him on that we'll get him on his
business we'll get him on his classified
documents we'll get and he's just
standing there that's what we have to do
don't move don't accommodate whatever
you do this is the lesson of the week
the lesson of the year from liz cheney
whatever you do do not
squish it always amuses me when people
use the phrase educate yourself as a
retort
because the people who do that sort of
thing are almost always the least
educated people out there
they are the ones who need that
education they would do very well to
tune into ben's book club which is back
tonight 8 pm eastern on
dailywireplus.com this month's book is
east of eden possibly john steinbeck's
greatest novel tune in to hear ben
discuss the novel share his notes with
you you've got to be an all access
member to join in on the fun go to
dailywireplus.com become a member today
join ben tonight 8pm eastern
donald trump is doubling down by the way
he is getting more and more provocative
by the day trump is now not only
endorsing the republicans who run
against the squishes he's now even
endorsing some democrats
trump is endorsing
dan goldman who's running for congress
in new york
he says lawyer dan goldman is running
for congress new york's 10th it's my
great honor to strongly endorse him
i do this not because of the fact that
he headed up the impeachment committee
and lost
but because he was honorable fair and
highly intelligent while it was my honor
to beat him and beat him badly dan
goldman has a wonderful future ahead
he'll be very compassionate and
compromising to those within the
republican party
[Music]
and will do everything possible to make
sure they have a fair chance at winning
against the radical left democrats who
he knows are destroying our country i
would like to thank dan for fighting so
hard for america and for working so
tirelessly to stop trump
he was not easy to beat but winning
against him made me realize just how
very talented i am
this is why he's going to be the nominee
guys
this is why i know i know there are
other candidates
there are other candidates who are doing
a good job
in their current roles
and who could very possibly do a good
job as president
and who very possibly at least in terms
of
public policy maybe they could do a
better job than trump i don't know i'm
not saying they could i'm saying it's
possible
you think about
ron desantis in florida you think about
ted cruz
uh he's probably the leading senate
candidate for president you've got
desantis for sure the leading governor
candidate for president there are others
too
but this guy if this guy wants it
this guy's going to get it
not only because he's leading 40 points
in the polls not only because the feds
raided his house galvanizing support for
him on the right but he's just
so funny he's so entertaining
and i think
not for us the people who tune into this
show are high information
very very politically involved
interested people okay by definition i'm
not flattering you if you're listening
to this show means you're consuming
political content
you're consuming it in a kind of
nitty-gritty fairly high-level way
that does not characterize most of the
country
no knock on most of the country most of
the country has other things to do
they're just not interested they have
other interests
and i think for most people
we're not tuning in to the latest who
did liz cheney beat this person and did
this what did steve bannon say about
this person and
for your regular guy who just tunes in
every so often
trump is freaking hilarious he did a
good job as president he's got universal
name recognition and he keeps you
entertained and in every presidential
contest
certainly at my lifetime but going back
much further i think the more
charismatic entertaining candidate won
trump obviously 2016
obama 2012 and 2008 bush 04 and 2000 oh
my gosh bush was running against
thurston howell iii
certainly much more entertaining clinton
against dole clinton against bush
the first
reagan against mondale and carter reagan
against bush in the primaries
on and on and on
and trump is that guy it's not just dan
goldman i'm going to read the other one
too he just trump just endorsed carolyn
maloney carolyn maloney is one of the
leading democrats in the house she's
been there for a long time
trump says a vote for
i can't even get through it a vote for
carolyn maloney in new york 12 is a vote
for the future
she is a kind and wonderful person who
has always said terrific things about me
and will support me no matter what i do
just as i supported her very early on
she begged for a check with no quid pro
quo and i gave it to her in fact i gave
her many
on the other hand jerry nadler is
likewise a hard-driving man of the
people whose energy and attention to
detail is unlike anyone else in congress
he is high-energy sharp quick-witted and
bright
you can't go wrong with either but
carolyn maloney is the better man
she will lead our country into a very
green and prosperous future carolyn has
my complete and total endorsement she
will never let our conservative movement
down
it's a work of art and i will never
forgive jack dorsey for kicking that man
off of twitter and depriving us of that
for a year
until he got truth social up and now at
least you can kind of see it when people
repost it on twitter
i will i will never that is so funny
because we know that trump despises
carol and maloney and especially jerry
nadler he's been brutal to jerry nadler
he calls him fat jerry
it's so he's so mean to these people and
then he realizes if he endorses them
that's bad for them
and so he does it in this absolutely
hilarious way
and that's that
the test the real final test of trump
2024 is going to be the midterm
elections it's why
at least the people around him
are urging him to wait until after the
midterms to declare
i think probably that's what he's going
to do
liz cheney's loss is a big win for trump
had tr had liz cheney won
had adam kinzinger been able to even run
for re-election
any of these people if the anti-trump
house republicans had won
trump would be seriously weakened going
into 2024
but they're almost all losing
so that is a big big boost for
trump and that's a big knock to the
other republicans who many of whom are
great people and would make great
presidents but that's a real knock to
them who are seeking the highest office
in the land all these republican
politicians speaking of the world's
oldest professions politics and one
other one a texas child protective
services employee
was just caught on camera telling a 14
year old girl in foster care to become a
prostitute
child protective services fires an
employee caught on camera telling a 14
year old girl in foster care to be a
prostitute but that state agency said
nothing about the video's existence
during a recent
fox 26's randy wallace joins us live
from downtown with that exclusive randy
[Applause]
yes sherman you would think the judge
overseeing the 14 year old girl's
custody case would need to know about
the cell phone video but apparently cps
didn't think so
she's a mother of nine
and she does have a daughter who has had
some behavioral problems that's why
keisha basley turned to child protective
services but then her 14-year-old
daughter told her when she told a cps
employee she was hungry that worker told
her to become a prostitute the daughter
recorded the cps worker on her cell
phone
if you gonna be a hoe be a real hoe so
says the child protective services
employee thankfully the cps employee has
been fired
horrible story
why do i even bring it up on the show
yeah terrible things happen in foster
care terrible things happen in these
bureaucratic agencies especially cps so
that's not exactly a man bites dog story
the reason i bring it up on this show
is i gotta ask i sometimes
ask this question
when you see a really outrageous story
and we all know it's so wrong but i
asked this question because of all the
confusion in our culture why is this
wrong
why is it wrong why is it wrong
that the child protective services
employee told the 14 year old girl
to be a hoe
and to
make a lot of money
selling her body for sex
why is it wrong
we are told in our culture that sex work
is real work we are told in our culture
that prostitution really should be
legalized
people should be able to do whatever
they want with their bodies people own
their bodies and they have a right to do
with their bodies whatever they so
please we're told this by the people on
the left we're even told by a lot of the
people on the right especially the
people who who
ascribe to a kind of extreme
libertarianism and who worship at the
altar of the free market
why should you not have the right to
sell your body for sex
even a lot of people on the right who
say look you know i'm conservative but
you know people want to do whatever with
their body that's not my business
so there's no according to
probably most people in the country at
least if you were to ask them about
their their conscious ideology they'd
say yeah there's nothing really wrong
with prostitution but they'd say there's
a problem because this is a kid
yeah okay
yeah it's a kid i know that's wrong but
the libs don't think that the libs
believe not only should kids be able to
engage in sexual activity and they
encourage sexual activity among kids
and not just even the radical pro
pedophilia normalize the minor attracted
person maps lunatics but everyone who
suggests we give
condoms to minors that we give we put
minors on birth control young teenagers
in many cases
they are encouraging sexual activity
among little kids but forget about that
for a second
we've got now got
the mainstream democrats up to and
including the white house
encouraging kids not just to have sexual
activity and consent to sexual activity
but to consent to permanent sexual
activity through transgenderism
not just a one-night stand not just be a
real hoe at the local motel we're saying
and the white house is saying little
girls minors can consent to having their
wombs cut out
that that little boys and little girls
can consent to being put on cross-sex
hormones making permanent sexual
decisions that could sterilize them a
hell of a lot more significant a hell of
a lot more traumatic than a one-night
stand or be a real hoe much more
significant than whatever the cps
employee is saying so what's wrong with
this
the reason it's wrong
is because all those premises are wrong
because you don't have a right to do
whatever you want with your body because
there is no right to prostitution
because some sexual behaviors are
obviously wrong even if it's between
consenting people and because kids can't
give consent
and because
we need to protect kids and and make
proper decisions on their behalf and
those decisions need to be based on an
objective moral order not the crazy
sexual fantasies of the left that's why
it's all wrong
and we should be able to use this wisdom
we know
that this stuff is wrong
there's so many things in society we
look at it we just say uh gosh i know
that's wrong it's called the wisdom of
repugnance and then we just convince
ourselves it's okay
we we allow ideology to convince us that
our intuitions are wrong our intuitions
are prejudice
the true prejudice meaning are just
natural judgments that we have of all
sorts of terrible things those are good
those are reliable those we should we
should generally defer to those
we should examine them but we should
defer to those in a lot of cases
inherited wisdom tradition
those are good things those are the
conservative insights okay that's what
we've got to rely on
if we throw that out the window we give
the culture to the libs
the rest of the show
is continuing now
but not for you
not for you if you're not watching this
on the daily wire if you're on youtube
if you're on apple podcast if you're on
spotify or stitch or whatever
if you're the hoi polloi
too cheap to go join and become a daily
wire member for goodness sakes you're
not going to get it but we've got a
great daily wire reporter mary margaret
olahan coming up and i've got my assault
rosary i've got my high capacity assault
rosary here we're going to talk about
the craziest news stories out of the
atlantic and the increase in attacks on
christians and on conservatives heading
into
the midterms if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]
you